the Joe Rogan experience right just just
started thinking about that thing you
did was it Ronda Rousey and who else was
in my what else that guy you said was
president oh that guy that's right Trump
was in it yeah oh I bet my balls and
lost what year was that those 15 those
before the elections yeah oh yeah I was
like right when he announced that he was
around the time yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
is he doing
yeah did you get all the different Ronda
Rousey versions no I look like I know
we've got um miss miss uh
Krissi cyborgs in there we have a Miss
Holly Holm we have cat Zingano we have
me we have Ronda I'm the hot one it's
all arias no again where do you have the
time to do this I didn't mean is that
these are friends of mine who did the
whole video I go here's what I have in
mind and they were like okay we'll do it
I don't mana mate I have no idea how to
animate you got a lot of [ __ ] for this
uh not really I mean cuz it's it's just
pure it's you know it's just pure comedy
but it's like it's not you know whatever
I'm not you know I I'm political to a
point
only when it's like when it comes to
[ __ ] so I don't like most
politicians are easy targets because
they're you're already know they're
lying brother speaking so that they're
just it's good comedy right away I think
the best comedy we've had in many years
his pen Trump cuz he just he sets him up
for you he does but it's almost it's
it's what he's doing is so strange
because he's not even pretending to be
what we think of as a president like
he'll attack people on Twitter yeah like
he it's weird crazy it's weird like I
wonder if the thing we talked about the
400-year line okay this is me going back
to conspiracy theories and there's no
head you didn't sneak in yet nobody's
working no all right
so class right
I feel like it's almost like that is the
distraction to keep us all divided and
keep us all guessing what the [ __ ]
going on on purpose
yeah maybe maybe you know if you're if
you're a good if you're good conspiracy
theorist
you're gonna put those connections
together look look at the every show
that's ever gone like okay well we find
out that there's just meteor speeding
toward Earth we can't tell anybody
hmm so if there's anything weird like
that going on like there's a there's a
fungus that's gonna kill everybody don't
tell me just cambrie arguing get them
like you know distracted by you know you
know football hey who's which who's your
team football right you know just the
bread and circus of it all mmm you get
caught up and having you know having
food and some gladiators and you forget
about your civic duty right that would
have to be orchestrated by some genius
component of our government that doesn't
seem honest and then I think it's
accident I don't think anybody I don't
think about pulling the strings I think
it's just like part of the progression
of what happens okay what happened the
kali-yuga madness it just yeah just so
just it because of the natural
progression of where things are going it
just comes out as a symptom that makes
more sense
yeah that that that makes more sense to
me than this grand conspirator
I don't think there's I don't think
anybody is that organized no I don't
think so yeah I think there's chaos
going on at people capitalizing on that
chaos and I definitely think there's
lying and I definitely think there's
conspiracies but I think more than
anything it's just this is the way the
world is turning right now because of
just how society is set up and how
disconnected we are to the natural world
and how connected we are to the digital
world and it's and there's I don't think
there's any way out but I think in the
interim I feel like at an attempt to
reconnect is gonna help I think
generally generationally there's a way
out the problem is for our generation I
don't know if there's a way out you know
I think especially people like us that
grew up without any sort of internet and
then have watched it transform and
completely take over the world
whereas the idea of a world without
internet is
impossible to us it doesn't even compute
but we grew up without it so what
happened well we were taken over were
taken over by some sort of digital
entity I don't think for us I think that
this world has to be figured out by the
people that recognize that we've [ __ ]
up like we were talking about learning
from mistakes learn from other people's
mistakes well they're gonna learn from
our mistakes they're gonna learn from
our mistakes and they're gonna see
people who grew up just like I mean like
every other really [ __ ] up part of
human civilization that people have
managed to overcome and avoid whether
it's slavery or war with bows and arrows
like they've figured out like that was
not the way to do it let's move past
this let's figure out what the folly of
our ancestors was and let's let's adjust
accordingly I agree with them
[Applause]